[Music]
you pelted an opponent once with
potatoes that's true that's true welcome
to the world that WWE yeah but so you
know was it it was it an I rose it was
it an Irish opponent is that what was
that was behind it no it was a it was
called Dublin Street fight I was in this
ongoing feud of the guy called damien
sandow at the time and obviously but
never getting the chance to get home as
much as I'd like to I got a bit homesick
so I thought a Dublin Street fight would
be a good way to kind of finish off the
rivalry we had and a you know we had
everything from like kegerators for
gainer guinness kegs
we had like tricolor Irish tricolour
coloured candlesticks we had a hammer
are still shamrock you can't you can't
beat em Rock no yeah but yeah so we had
two dozen street fight and I brought
everything out especially the sack of
potatoes cuz everyone knows like
potatoes are literally the first thing
that's putting your plate if you're from
Ireland the first yes first food or
fruit or whatever it's called it goes
and goes into play with everything else
that's the primary food source is
potatoes so I thought bag potatoes would
be very fitting for Dublin Street fight
and of course not only did I use them as
a weapon but I also used them as a
nutrition meal a nutritious meal yeah
you know I was amazes me is that auntie
old test to this I grew up in what I
thought was just a sophisticated
household of like my dad's a doctor my
mother's a lawyer growing up it's like
the late-1970s we've been in this
country for 120 150 years at that point
you think that we'd have moved past
there were potatoes at every single meal
and everywhere in our kitchen
there were potatoes and my brothers and
I used to get into fights and we would
throw potatoes at each other because
that was was in the kitchen we had
potatoes on hand they hurt and they
really it's a great weapon really are
your weapon you get in trouble if you
get backed into a corner out there and
there's a potato around choose that yeah
the yam right the yam is not a deadly
yeah not deadly at all it's pretty
pretty it's pretty aggressive weapon on
yeah it's in our genetic code to have
those things around all the time
specially your grandmother's trona
matcha your grandmother throw potatoes
out a couple of times yeah when I was
younger she could actually play baseball
but a baseball isn't really played in
Ireland but she was really good yeah
yeah so she could have come too
American played baseball if they had
allowed her to use a potato instead of
him
she's like I'm real good but there's one
catch
only put on but only if I'm naming the
Seamus Seamus I was the thing yeah but I
have to say this like I really really
wanted to come here tonight and I really
wanted to have a hawk off rakonin
because I felt like you know my
situation was I had the same hair for a
while the character was one changeup or
I really wanted to do like have a hawk
off because I always tell people you got
to respect the hawk you know I'm saying
that people tell me I look stupid or I
miss out there now no respect the hawk
[Applause]
and I think I think we're gonna send a
great opportunity because I think Kona
yes
hey Felix
[Applause]
you broke my collarbone
you